what's going on everyone axel beats here
for anime uproar and today we're taking
a look at all of the non-canon devil
fruit in one piece devil fruits have
always been an iconic part of the series
and as we've received so many movies
games and filler episodes over the 25
plus year run there's definitely been
more than enough to talk about you know
the drill though if you are enjoying the
one piece content on the channel
remember to leave a like and a comment
down below and of course if you haven't
subscribed to the channel make sure you
do so so that you don't miss any of our
future videos first up i want to give a
big thank you to today's sponsor
re-fantasia charm and conquer for
supporting our channel you guys know how
much we love anime and manga here but
some of you might not know that we
actually love isakai so much that we
even had our own isakai light novel
series that's why we're so excited to
work with re fantasia as with all great
izakaya our story begins with a run-in
with truckcoon but you're instantly
transported to a magical world where you
run a medieval city filled with magic
battles and of course your own personal
harem of maids succubi and cat girls so
it has a bit of something for everyone
the game has a really interesting system
of progression as you train your troops
go on dates and win over the hearts of
your countrymen by making choices that
have real impact on the story on top of
that you can actually connect your
kingdom with your friends through
marrying off your heirs to make both of
your cities more powerful so don't
forget to look us up in game with the
username anime uproar and the id 105
47011 so that we can work together and
save the world with our harems not only
that but if you use the code 1luvrf
you'll get two glass brushes two clovers
and 100 crystals free to help you kick
off your journey check it out for free
with the link in the description as is
tradition in this series there are a lot
more paramecia than logia or zone so
let's start with the smaller group and
move on to the big ones kicking things
off with the logia there have been a
total of three logia fruit introduced
outside of the main series however it's
been a pretty long time since we've seen
them our first logia fruit was the toro
toronomi or the fluid fluid fruit this
was eaten by honeyqueen in the second
one-piece movie clockwork island
adventure this fruit allowed the user to
become and produce a pink syrupy liquid
it enabled honeyqueen to pass through
small spaces and avoid attacks however
for some reason and let's be real we all
know the reason she wasn't able to keep
her clothes like other logia fruit users
do
the main weakness of the torotoranomi is
that honeybee is unable to turn back
into her normal body if she's in a space
that she would be too small to fit in
which does make sense however this
allows nami to very easily capture her
just by simply putting her in a jar from
a movie to a game we jump to the pasa
pasanomi or the paper paper fruit this
was eaten by simon in the one piece
great hidden treasure of the seven
phantom islands game this fruit allows
the user to turn into tiny sheets of
paper so that they can dodge attacks and
inflict thousands of tiny paper cuts on
their opponents this is basically a mix
of kaluto from hunter hunter and konan
from naruto simon also infused his
papers with ancient symbols allowing him
to imbue them with extra effects like
fire resistance creating explosions
poisoning his enemies etc on top of that
by transforming into paper he's able to
fly which puts him in a pretty exclusive
group of devil fruit users and finally
the ame amenomi or the candy candy fruit
this was eaten by gaspard in one piece
movie 4 dead end adventure and the fruit
allows gaspard to create and turn into
green candy syrup which despite being
candy is unfortunately unedible on top
of this despite devil fruits supposedly
being an intuitive thing gaspard seems
to have not mastered the logia part of
his fruit yet as he can still be struck
when he's not paying attention his
intangibility could also just be turned
off if he came in contact with flour
which is a very specific weakness
in general this fruit could be used to
create traps for his opponents slowing
them down in his syrup and then using
the opportunity to just jump on them or
he could turn parts of his body into
spikes and then harden it or use his
goop in a more similar way to luffy and
his stretching abilities but that's
actually it for the logia so let's move
on to the zones zoens tend to not be as
flashy as logia fruit which is probably
why we have twice as many non-canon
zones as we do from logia starting off
with the two tori torinome or bird bird
fruits we have firstly is model eagle
which made an appearance in movie 11 one
piece 3d straw hat chase
this fruit was eaten by the dog named
buzz and allowed him to turn into an
eagle while also obviously having a
hybrid form most of the zone fruits
we're going to talk about are just
transformed form hybrid form that's it
that's kind of how the fruits work
unfortunately there's not a whole lot
more detail to them more importantly
though i hadn't seen this movie before
and good lord is it so ugly the other
bird bird fruit that we had was actually
the mythical model nue this fruit was
created for and first seen at the one
piece kyoto event to celebrate the 20th
anniversary the story is that toratsuku
found it as he escaped prison in wano
and after eating it he was able to turn
into the mythical yokai the nue as well
as obviously having an in-between form
for those who don't know the nue is
basically the japanese chimera often
seen with pheasant or tiger-like
features sometimes having a monkey's
face or a tanooki's body or a snake tail
it's a very malleable creature and
depending on the story it's going to
have slightly different traits but
basically it's extremely cool and i wish
we could have seen it animated for our
named zones we actually only have two
left each being from the unlimited world
red game and each being mythical zones
firstly we have the bato baton me or bat
bat fruit model vampire this was eaten
by patrick redfield the main antagonist
of the game and allowed him to become a
vampire with this he could fly he had
the ability to shroud himself in
darkness or teleport through bursts of
blood and all that is extremely badass
the fruit's biggest strength though is
allowing redfield to suck someone's life
energy from them by biting their neck or
digging his nails into their skin
allowing him to regain his own youth and
making him effectively immortal it kinda
makes me wish that we had more monster
themed fruits in thriller bark but
unfortunately
we just had moria
redfield also had a pen called patto and
much like mr four's gun or spondom sword
patto also ate a devil fruit this being
the inuinu nomi model bake danuki or the
dog dog fruit model monster tanooki as i
said it's another mythical zone which
allows pato the pen to transform create
objects and even summon attacks from
other characters for example anil's
lightning or kuzon's ice by means of
using leaves as a medium but with those
out of the way we can move on to the
three unnamed zone non-canon devil
fruits as well and as these don't have
names i'm gonna go ahead and name them
that sounds kind of fun and we're going
to be starting with cheeky cheetah of
the foxy pirates who has a cheetah-based
devil fruit that gives him increased
speed likely the cat cat fruit model
cheetah al pacochino is shuzu's bazooka
who ate an alpaca fruit this allows him
to spit cannonballs from his mouth and
even infuse hockey into them if i had to
name it i'd probably go with something
like the horsehorse fruit model alpaca i
know it's not an actual horse but a lot
of zones seem to fall under umbrellas of
similar shape and form animals for
example all the dinosaurs being ryu ryu
or dragon dragon fruits or the kitsune
being a dog dog variant rather than a
fox that plus we already have one horse
horse fruit so we know the category
exists so i think it's decently likely
and finally we have all hunt grounds
fruit all hunt is a marine who worked
under aokiji and his fruit is incredibly
interesting and that's because rather
than allowing for a full or hybrid
transformation like most other zones all
it did was transform his left arm this
arm becomes massive covered in red fur
it's tremendously powerful and it's just
really cool it seems to be gorilla's arm
but the red fur and a limited area can
make it a little bit hard to tell but
for now we're just going to go with the
monkey monkey fruit model gorilla and
with that we have the end of our 10
logia and zone non-canon fruits and we
can finally move our way into the many
many non-canon paramecia the first of
which we saw in one piece the movie the
goegoenomi or the screamscream fruit was
eaten by eldorago and it's a pretty
simple fruit allowing for him to shout
very powerful sound blasts out of his
mouth it's kind of like an
oversimplified version of a pu's otonomi
but even for being something so simple
the screamstream fruit can be pretty
destructive however just like any other
sound wave it can be bounced back or
deflected especially if you're battling
a particularly bouncy boy and this can
cause it to backfire quite a bit
seemingly the exact opposite of
screaming we have the hiso hisonomi or
the whisper whisper fruit which was
eaten by apiece in the warship island
arc this allows her to speak with and
understand animals such as the dragons
that inhabit the island interestingly
enough this arc also showed us that
luffy was able to communicate with the
dragon on some level being our first
look at the voice of all things and if
it wasn't the actual first look it's
certainly one of the first and i know
it's not super relevant here but it's
something cool that no one ever talks
about and it's my video so i'm gonna put
it in warship island also introduces us
to eric and his kamakama nomi or the
sickle sickle fruit this allows eric to
create sickles out of the air and launch
them at his opponents it's a very simple
fruit but any ability that produces some
kind of blade or sharp edge especially
early on was something that luffy really
struggled with so it was at least
somewhat interesting for the time
oh and before we move on remember when
nami just
kills this dude by knocking him off the
merry on reverse mountain dude is a
devil fruit user and 100 percent cannot
swim it's basically gg meaning nami is
the first straw hat to kill someone on
screen something i really liked about
this arc in particular is that
throughout the east blue we only saw a
few devil fruits total we had luffy
buggy alvida smoker and probably dragon
it's a pretty limited group and it's
usually one per arc if that but this arc
we suddenly have too yes it's filler but
i always really appreciated that the
closer we got to the grand line we
suddenly have more and more devil fruits
becoming more common anyways moving on
to the second movie one piece clockwork
island adventure in this movie we have
the kachikachi nomi or the hard hard
fruit this was eaten by bear king and
allows him to harden any part of his
body making it very difficult to injure
him and allowing his attacks to have a
lot more impact he can also heat up his
fists which allows him to burn his
enemies with his punches the nemu nemu
nomi or the sleep sleep fruit was eaten
by the seahorse noko who is the main
antagonist of the one piece ocean's
dream video game this was later brought
in for the anime only ocean stream arc
as well but the sleep sleep fruit allows
noko to trap people in dream worlds
while they sleep then he can steal their
memories to make himself stronger noko
can also hypnotize people create
illusions from the smoke that he
produces and can even paralyze others as
he steals their memories next up a
really cool one the mini mini nomi a
fruit which was introduced under two
different users depending on which
medium you're looking at in the one
piece round the land game for ps2 it was
used by
blue buildu
i don't know how to pronounce this but
in the z's ambition arc it was instead
eaten by lily the glutton whose name is
much easier to pronounce the mini mini
fruit is a really fun one allowing its
user to shrink down to 5 millimeters
tall but at the same time allowing them
to keep all of their normal strength
obviously they can become any size in
between as well from their normal height
to that five millimeters tall the fruit
also extends to the wearer's clothes and
weapons and on top of that both of the
users that we see are normally giants so
they have a ton of strength packed into
quite literally a very tiny package on
to the ice hunter arc where we have
acino and his atsu atsunomi or the hot
hot fruit it allows him to heat himself
up to 10 000 degrees and once he's
heated he can shoot steam out of his
nose to float melt anything he touches
and even affect the air around him
launching pockets of hot air through his
punches i was also 100 sure that his
sons with the weird magnet power were
also devil fruit users but i guess they
were just naturally able to do that so
if you guys would want a video on
non-devil fruit users with cool powers
like them or miss golden week let us
know we'll get it out for you next up
though we have the nokonoko nomi or the
shroom shroom fruit from the ninth one
piece movie episode of chopper and the
miracle winter cherry blossom the shrimp
fruit was eaten by mushrooru who was
waffle's older brother the fruit allows
him to create poisonous mushroom spores
both in mist or energy blasts he can
create and control clones transform his
body into several different attacking
forms by producing mushrooms it's
definitely one of the weirder fruits out
there and it absolutely is one that
pushes the envelope of the idea of what
a fruit actually does
in the little east blue arc we met largo
the captain of the amigo pirates who had
the ani aminomi or the net net fruit
this allowed him to just generally
create nets on top of this he can infuse
whatever he eats or drinks into the nets
that he produces so if he eats metal if
he eats hot water or if he eats fire he
can create nets out of those things
which is pretty awesome finally he can
also turn his own body into a net as
well and make himself immune to physical
blows
next up moving on to the one piece
premiere show something that's going to
show up more and more in this list as it
continues in 2012 we had chameleon who
ate the coffee copy nomi which allowed
him to copy the devil fruit abilities of
others film z also brought a few new
devil fruits with it first with the moto
moto nomi or the return return fruit
this is probably one of my favorite that
the franchise has ever had to offer this
fruit was eaten by ain and allowed her
to de-age anyone that she touched by 12
years and this can also be done several
times if need be even until the target
is unborn and basically dies this
obviously draws comparisons to bonnie's
devil fruit but the major difference is
that the motomoto is more limited in the
changes it can actually make with the
trade-off that it can affect non-living
beings as well and as i mentioned this
fruit doesn't seem to have a limit as
well going backwards whereas i'd imagine
bonnie can't unborn someone back to the
idea of being used on non-living things
though the motomoto can de-age things
like igneous rock into magma or if a
piece of wall or ground is broken it can
be reformed or used to surround someone
to basically make it a trap it is a
super interesting fruit and it does not
hurt even a little bit how cute the user
is a less cute user though is bins who
has the mosamosa nomi or the grosgrow
fruit also introduced in the same movie
it allows him to make plants grow and
then control them it's basically the
devil fruit version of usopp's pop
greens and while bins is pretty lame the
fruit is pretty cool the next fruit has
two origin points first seen in the one
piece premiere show for 2013 and used by
lambert bikini but in the anime it was
found during the silver mine arc and
used by bill the smelt smelt fruit
allows the user to become a human
furnace bill could eat ore and then turn
it into whatever he might need at any
given time blades guns mine carts armor
if it can be made from the ore that he
consumes he can produce it whenever he
wants he can also coat his body in
silver armor attack with molten oar and
it's apparently strong enough to melt an
entire island lambert's fruit was more
or less the same except he didn't need
to consume or to use this power the pito
pitonomi or the pet pet fruit was used
by breed in the caesar retrieval arc
this allowed breed to create collars
which would force the wearer to obey him
he could also put colors on himself to
reach his own full potential or even
beyond for example giving him the
ability to levitate it's important to
note that this fruit isn't all powerful
though while they must obey any order
they need to be able to actually hear
the order and understand it for it to
work
on top of that he only controls their
actions through the commands so in
between the commands they're free to act
or plot however they'd like and with
that we're up to the 2014 premiere show
with the kone kone nomi or the need need
fruit this was eaten by bildy and allows
the user to transform targets into other
people this transformation also copies
the abilities and strengths of that
person but cannot be used on the user
themselves we saw bildy making fake
versions of hody jones crocodile luchi
kid buggy mr three boa law and orrs so
it's a pretty useful tool if you're
trying to give your army a boost the
2014 show also had smash and his zuma
zuma fruit or the plasma plasma fruit
this allowed him to create manipulate
and turn into plasma as he saw fit
typically this was shown through him
creating large electricity balls
the moa moa nomi or the mormor fruit was
used by brindi world brindy world they
give some of these strangest names to
these filler characters
introduced in the 3d2y special the more
more fruit allows its user to increase
the size and speed of whatever they
touch basically turning him into a
living catapult we've seen both speed
and size be multiplied up to a hundred
times
and it's pretty straightforward the
amount of damage that he'd be able to do
with this fruit also in 3d 2y we have
the kubu kubu fruit or the cube cube
fruit this allows anything that the user
gyram touches to be formed into a cube
this can also be channeled through his
hammer as well for extra range and power
gairam can break things down into tiny
cubes launch his cubes any directions he
wants stack them or even form air into
cubes that he can use as weapons as well
in the 2015 stage play lucy and lucy
coliseum the battle we have the maji
majinomi or the magic magic root which
allows the user inchiken to perform
stage magic such as illusions
hypnotizing and escaping from his
opponents the 2015 premiere show brought
us two new devil fruits with bursts nito
nito nomi or the nitro nitro fruit which
allows him to create explosions by
clapping or by impacting his opponents
we also got the horehorenomi which was
eaten by bon bon and this fruit causes
any living creature that he touches to
fall in love with him or anyone else
that he chooses they'll listen to
anything that he tells them to do
however this fruit will not affect
anyone who is already in love in film
gold we got the nuke nuke nomi or the
through through fruit eaten by tanaka
with this tanaka is able to phase
through solid objects allowing him to
travel through walls dodge attacks or
even make the floor intangible and cause
whoever standing on it to fall through
that said he is not able to affect other
living things i mentioned the silver
mine arc earlier but we also had the
koro koronomi in here or the roll roll
fruit this was eaten by avaron and has
the very specific ability of being able
to turn him into a mine cart
it also allows him to store things
inside of himself like cannons or
weapons but honestly this just kind of
feels like a very early version of
diesel's devil fruit from the whole cake
island arc the jada jara nomi or the
chain chain fruit was used by mad
treasure in the heart of gold special
mad is able to create chains of
seemingly any size from necklaces to
massive ones to hurt his opponents he
can also change what they're made of as
we see him using steel gold or even
diamond to make them weaker or stronger
and he can use these chains to strike
enemies capture them or even use
different tips for utility with things
like grappling hooks it's a very
versatile fruit which offers a lot of
extra options than you might expect the
iro ironomi or the color color fruit
also comes from heart of gold but was
used by psycho p this fruit allows the
user to camouflage themselves or
anything else making them practically
invisible even for objects as big as
ships psycopee can also use this fruit
to disguise people as others but it
doesn't work very well unless the person
they're trying to fool is pretty dumb
while his fruit might seem pretty strong
on paper it has a ton of flaws firstly
anyone with good observation hockey can
just still see you and second which is
probably more impactful is that he needs
a tool like a spray can to actually use
his fruit which is just so lame in film
gold we got the goru gorunomi or the
gold gold fruit this was eaten by the
antagonists of the movie guild tesero
and allows him to manipulate any gold
that he touches he can change it from
liquid to solid or back reshape it
however he sees fit and do whatever he
wants with it he can use it to surround
people encase them in gold or even
create armor for himself even being able
to turn himself into a massive golden
golem when awakened guild is able to
actually extend his senses through the
goal that he's controlling making it
this network of information for himself
it's a really cool fruit but it does
have some massive weaknesses firstly he
can't create gold himself so he has to
find and touch it and secondly if any of
the gold that he is controlling is
touched by seawater he loses control of
it more interesting to me this movie was
the rakiraki nomi or the lucky lucky
fruit this was used by bakarat and
allows her to steal luck from anyone
that she touches both making the target
very unlucky while she herself became
very lucky if she absorbs enough luck
she effectively becomes invincible as
the world around her will bend so that
she can't be harmed and so that she's
always successful the main downside of
this fruit is that the effects aren't
permanent and she'll basically need to
top up every now and then moving on to
the 2016 premier show with the nepa nepa
nomi or the wave wave fruit this allowed
vice admiral wilder to create heat waves
strong enough to destroy promised land
the heat waves can also be amplified or
directed through using a fan here we
also got the mono mononomi or the paste
paste fruit this was used by poke and
allowed him to create clones of people
or objects these clones had the same
abilities but were weaker than the
originals and included people like
magellan doflamingo crocodile moria and
even the going mary to name a few i am
noticing a trend in these premiere shows
where they love the idea of copying
characters and i would hope that this is
the last one because this is like the
third or fourth iteration of that one
piece live attraction 3 brought us the
introduction of anne who had the bijo
bijou nomi or the vision vision fruit
although we would later see her in
stampede as well and is able to create
illusions of any picture that she
touches which allows her to fool enemies
or bolster the morale of her allies the
ute utenomi or the gun gun fruit was
used by bad one gracie in the 2017
premier show this fruit allowed gracie
to transform anything around them into
guns or cannons and the scale is pretty
crazy as he can transform even chunks of
the sea massive walls or the entire
island into firearms
the major downside of this fruit is that
gracie's hands have also been
permanently turned into guns also in the
2017 premiere show we have the pocha
pocha nomi or the fat fat fruit this was
used by nero and allowed him to control
the level of fat in both his own and
other people's bodies the 2018 show
would give us bounty and her bona bona
nomi a fruit which allowed her to turn
the jealousy that she had into heat or
flames then using those to attack or
grab onto and burn the person we also
had prize and his daddy darinomi which
allowed prize to send any object or
person to any point that he could see
this includes weapons viruses poison
bombs or even someone's heart which is
an interesting fruit to say the least in
one piece novel law we got archer baca
and his derodera nomi which allowed him
to shoot beams from his eyes that cause
anything even themselves to dissolve
when in liquid form archer is immune to
physical attacks but is still
susceptible to electricity he can also
raise the acidity in his body to melt
anything that he touches
and finally archer can also dissolve
things metaphorically for example
melting your heart's resistance to him
and giving him control over you for 24
hours if this is not turned off in that
period whoever the target is will die
at the 2018 one-piece dramatic stage the
metal marine ford of remembrance event
we were introduced to the meta metanomi
or the metal metal fruit this allowed
the user gradle to control liquid metal
similar to mercury he was able to split
himself into many of these metal parts
and each part would be able to
communicate with each other and as is
tradition for live events any of those
parts could change their form to look
like someone else balzac
spelled b-a-l-z-a-c
and not the other way was introduced in
the 2019 premiere show
he had the basu basu nomi or the boom
boom fruit this is the reverse of mr
five's bomb bomb fruit which allowed him
to turn his own body into a bomb instead
balzac can turn anything they touch into
bombs more or less like kira from jojo's
part 4. douglas bullet in stampede had
the gasha gasha nomi or the clank clank
fruit allowing him to make machines by
assimilating the world around him using
a telekinetic power to disassemble or
assemble things however he'd like for
example producing a giant exoskeleton a
submarine or whatever else he might need
at any time
when awakened this fruit can also
manipulate the environment as well not
being limited to machinery next up is
the neebie nibinomi in the 2021 premiere
show this was used by cardia and it very
simply allows them to look like dead
people and finally we have utta's devil
fruit from film red the utta utta nomi
or the song song fruit this fruit allows
uta to send people's consciousness into
a virtual space called the uta world by
singing in this world she is basically
all-powerful controlling everything
around her and it's impossible for
anyone else to leave on their own she
has to open the door for them on top of
that she's able to control the actual
bodies of anyone trapped in her virtual
world the major downside of this fruit
is that utta is only able to keep utta
world open for as long as she is awake
and actually using her devil fruit is
extremely draining so it doesn't last
for super long and that is more or less
it with the exception
of three non-canon joke devil fruits
mentioned in sbs these being the barf
bar fruit which makes the user never
stop barfing the bad joke fruit which
forces you to tell bad jokes and the
itchy crotch fruit
so
yeah
while these were not created by oda they
are included in one piece mediums and if
i'm being honest we needed more fruit
anyways to hit that 50 mark so i'm gonna
appreciate you playing along but that
wraps up all of the paramusia bringing
us to 52 non-canon fruit total not all
of these are created equal and there are
definitely some that stand out well
above the rest to me i think that the
mini mini fruit the lucky lucky fruit
and the return return fruit all
are really really cool and i would love
to see more of them but i would love to
know which ones were your favorite so
let me know in the comments down below
and while you're down there remember to
support the channel by leaving a like
and don't forget to subscribe so you
don't miss any of our other great
one-piece content another massive thank
you to refantasia charm and conker for
sponsoring this video remember to check
them out in the description but with all
that being said thank you all so much
for watching and until next time
remember to stay excellent